i would say that a 21st century search
system doesn't look like a search system
at all i think the most interesting part
about where searches headed is that it
will become more ambient more
transparent I think in even Tim I don't
know five years ten years some time in
the future this notion of saying I'm
going to go search for that I'm going to
go search that i'm going to go google
that bing that will sound as outmoded as
someone saying i'm going to go get
online in the old days of before
broadband internet was wat broadly
distributed and before we had wireless
access everywhere you would have to
consciously say to yourself I'm going to
go dial up to AOL compuserve or these
old services and get online you had to
stop stop your train of thought
interrupt your task and do that and
search is kind of the same way today
when you think about it you have if
you're in the middle of something else
and you want to figure out the ratings
for a particular restaurant that your
uber is going to take you to you have to
switch apps and go to a search app and
punch it in and and that's that's very
disruptive where we're seeing now search
heading is it becoming more it's
becoming more interwoven throughout all
the different experiences so as you are
engaging in experiences anywhere search
that simply become relevant and become
part of that experience that you're that
you're engaging with so that's the first
thing I think you're going to see search
as this construct begin to blend into
the fabric of of what you're what you're
doing search will also however stop just
simply being an index we're already
seeing in many cases today search
creating knowledge synthesizing
knowledge and that's a pretty exciting
thing traditionally sorts has been all
about finding something somebody has
written or published or whatnot indexing
at retrieving it when someone asks a
question pertaining to it because of the
work that all these companies have done
over the last 15 years the ability for
search to physically understand the
world in which it lives is has been
boosted dramatically meaning that search
now has the ability to process the world
not just index but make sense of all
these things make sense of who I am make
sense of who I know make sense of what i
like and create content about me about
world in ways that just didn't exist and
so it's really exciting for nerds like
me because suddenly we're not just
retrieving things that already exist out
there we're finding patterns refining
insights we're finding things that no
one even knew using all this
computational power that we have so the
fact that you know heading down if I
have to go up to midtown today avoiding
a certain street because there's
congestion that's a very simple example
of what search has search has looked at
all the data coming in from all the
different cars and the street lights and
the cameras and whatnot and said there's
something happening here on on
thirty-eighth right so you should route
around that thing that isn't indexed
anywhere that is a that is a synthetic
creation of search so I think that's the
second second really exciting thing the
first one being in that kind of
transparency of it a second thing being
this predictive power and this creation
ability of it the last thing really I'm
most excited about is the ability that
will have to interact with it in new and
different ways and so in the same way
that is becoming more transparent search
will be able to again be ambient around
us and it will be something where you're
not even necessarily thinking about I
need to go search something you just as
you're engaging with something as you're
pointing at something as you're looking
at something depending on what you're
wearing as you're having a conversation
with somebody depending on what you
allow search to do it can be part of
your everyday corpus it's part of your
life and so it'll be something which is
listening and looking and thinking for
you and with you to augment your daily
life in ways that today it's very much a
conscious act that you have to go do so
that's that's kind of the third areas
it'll be an augmentation to your life in
ways that you haven't really explored
today
you